on a on a tous appris à l'école
les frontières c'est pointillés qui sont
sûres sur les cartes géographiques sur
les globes terrestres
c'est foncièrement j'arrivais quand
j'étais enfin à bien saisir le sens
surtout la frontière du ce est aussi
celle de l'est et de l'ouest parce que
ce sont des océans mais jamais les
professeurs arrivait à m'expliquer c'est
du nord ouest y était comment c'était
celui non et la question embarrassante
demande un professeur c'est avez vous
déjà été la seule du nord nous venons
non mais comment élire et sa piqué ma
curiosité ou professeurs disaient temps
en temps des sisters ou la maîtresse
d'école disait vers le nord vers le
grand nord
c'est la nature c'est ça que c'est le
grand froid ou mais ça répondait pas ma
question où est la frontière
je la regardais vue du ciel serein
docter reste sur la carte
je voyais bien si pointillés on m'a des
biens expliqué que que l'autre côté du
pointillés quelques font parler notre
langue
on avait surtout un autre drapeau on
avait d'autres règlements d'autres
quelquefois d'autres façons de vivre je
cerner bien lorsque je pouvais avec mon
doit faire le tour d'un pays et
j'arrivais mal à faire avec mon doigt le
tour du mien quand j'arrivais parlement
donc très jeune j'ai voulu essayer de
comprendre
je me suis préparé
jeune je dois vous avouer que à cet
âge-là je n'envisageais pas de me rendre
au nord
mais cette curiosité d'aller au bout la
boussole peux me rejoint peu peut
m'amener essayé de rejoindre l'horizon
essayer d'aller loin toujours plus loin
que là où mes yeux me permettent de voir
même si je grimpais sont débauchés
même si je répète dans les arbres je me
disais toujours mais qu'est-ce qui est
encore moins et d'autres questions
venait mais pour moi je voulais je
voulais me rends je voulais savoir je
voulais connaître chose rapidement je
suis tombé en amour avec yves aris me
poser comme question mais où est ce qui
est vert dans ma tête
l'été des aînés dans le sahara mais
l'hiver il est né on me parle du père
noël mais d'où vient le vent s'est
froissé me voler mon visage
les partis dits c'est ce qui m'a attiré
a fortement regard de leur apporter mon
regard et à prendre les moyens d'essayer
de me rentrer avec l'effort que cela
demande
avec dans son sac à dos dans son
traîneau beaucoup d'autonomie mais un
gros poids de passion et de curiosité la
plus belle qualité qu'on peut savoir se
garder la naïveté de son enfance la
curiosité et sa capacité de
s'émerveiller
voilà pourquoi je me prends à attendre
des parrains dire à leurs enfants
nady puce intégrant maintenant laisser
le psy ou les laisser rêver s'il veut le
faire lui aussi
le tour du monde le nord m'a appris ici
en irak qui avait pas juste que le froid
n'est je prenais conscience que c'est
l'endroit dans notre pays
l'article et le wat et c'est l'endroit
qui a été le plus difficile à découvrir
c'est là où sont inscrits les plus
grands exploits
il est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
difficile à l'époque de trouver ce
fameux passage d'une angoisse que la
source du nil beaucoup plus cela a coûté
des vies à des milliers d'explorateurs
l'époque alao arctique quelque part une
petite île rocheuse
on appelle les litchis il y à ces tombes
des sites de ces jeunes marins qui ont
accompagné franklin à la recherche du
passage nord-ouest
on a essayé pendant 100 ans lorsque
franklin n'est jamais revenu saddam à
londres riche de surcroît ne croyait pas
que son mari pouvait être mort au milieu
de nulle part au menu des plats chauds
ou du monde elle a donc commandé 20
expéditions de recherche à faire
construire des bateaux on n'essayait
même de trouver ce qu'ils se sont perdus
et ceux qui cherchaient ceux qui sont
perdus certains d'entre eux ne revenez
pas ces pages d'histoire montagny aussi
à savoir que la frontière du nord m'a
porté par simplement que des notions de
joux a fui et c'est le d'histoire et
faisait réveiller en moi
ce que nous avons tous d'ailleurs cette
graine de l'avant sur le vouloir
connaître de ce qu'on ne sait pas le
propre de l'intelligence de vouloir
aller là où l'on croit que peu de gens
sont allés 7
cet adn d'aventuré les en chacun d'entre
nous ces tempêtes on en a besoin elles
nous bouscule elle nous ramène à la
réalité
elle nous rend humble et on le voit avec
ce qui se passe actuellement
elle nous rend humble nous amène à
concevoir notre planète autrement
de temps en temps une bonne tempête nous
y vous êtes petit et cette planète
on a toujours citoyen en lui tapant sur
l'épaule à main pointe à tout ce qu'elle
pouvait nous donner
je crois mon simple avis que nous
devrons devrions commencer là vous voyez
ça t'a proche de la nature
cette puissance m'a appris beaucoup de
choses
j'ai appris le sait avec l'altitude ce
que cela donne de la profondeur allant
j'ai appris que le que le froid
m'entouraient meurin des humbles mais
aussi plus forts ayant confiance à mon
expérience et a émis l'avis j'ai pour
cela
regardez vers le nord il n'y avait pas
que de la glace
il y avait eu aussi peu qui mentalement
enseigné sur l'art de s'adapter eux
vivent dans ce pays d'
deux classes de froid et qui savent
sourire à la plus forte des emprunts eux
qui montrent un enseignant qui j'apporte
un grand respect mais vu aujourd'hui
plusieurs d'entre eux vivent dans un
climat social à ces dérives ils ont eux
aussi à leur façon
sculpter leur environnement eux aussi
peu ils ont su apprendre de la banque
écoutez la force et le vin de la main ce
fut pour plusieurs d'entre eux leurs
plus grandes écoles est température
change ce type ce monsieur que vous
voyez il ya peu d'années ils n'avaient
jamais entendu le domaine jamais ce
n'est jamais assez chaud et assez humide
pour que les orages se forme
j'essaie quelquefois de m'imaginer cet
homme devant chez lui au bord de l'elbe
et entendre le tonnerre
d'ailleurs cette anecdote 7 mai une zee
soit vous dans le ce vous avez des
montres
nous on a le temps
ces étendues immenses l'homme même
l'occasion d'être le premier à quelle
sensation de s'en aller droit devant et
à mesure oui il ya eu des photos
satellites de ces endroits
oui on connaît mais tous ces montagnes
ne porte pas de mon nature on lui doit
tout et de puissants et je laime j'ai
appris à aimer l'hiver et on est devenus
de grands corps et le froid n'a jamais
du vam a jamais voulu faire de mal à
quiconque
il s'est simplement un désir de faire
attention et d'apprendre du bien le vin
est d'être capable de lui parut cette
nature elle m'a toujours entouré elle
m'a appris tant de choses
elle réveille un mois à tous les jours
cette envie de vouloir partir de vouloir
la retrouver allez rencontrer encore sa
puissance de m'en aller loin sur la cas
à la recherche de ceux qui ont étudié
que l'on appelle les frontières voici le
meilleur douaniers dronne il ne laisse
pas passer n'importe qui c'est curieux
mais l'ours est devenu un symbole pour
nous tous et pourtant je suppose que
très très peu d'entre nous ont vus ours
l'ours ne collaborent pas notre commune
l'ours ne nourrit pas pourtant on aime
tout ce qu'on veut le protéger protéger
sans vouloir le voir protéger en sachant
qu'il est très loin pas protégé pour
quelque chose qu'on côtoie tous les
jours
l'essai de protéger un symbole
probablement parce qu'on voit en bourse
l'humanité on voit un lorsqu'ils tentent
une période de survie et on se voit
aussi comme ça donc vaut mieux
transporter notre part sur un animal qui
a beaucoup des suites à sourire que son
hymen
si l'ours avec ses pattes elle à sa
démarche fut vaine si lorsque nous
amener à mener la réflexion
eh bien il restera le plus grand de tous
les animaux on est toujours seul même si
on part à plusieurs on est toujours seul
lorsque on agit même communauté
on est seul dans ses pensées dans ses
rêves c'est bien d'essayer de savoir ce
que l'autre veut aussi le médecin
ensemble pour mettre une énergie commune
mais cette passion ce rêve ses idées
elles naissent en vous seul pas deux
personnes à la fois j'ai gm immo et
j'aime encore grand lahou le professeur
chen su m'expliquer où étaient ces
français avant moment mais aujourd'hui
je suis persuadé que si on se penche
tous ensemble partout sur la planète
pour prendre la marque quitter ce cri
par terre et la menée haut car nous
aurions sûrement sûrement un monde
meilleur
[Applaudissements]